نقدية متعددة الاطراف. اعلن
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوجان
زيادة اجور العمالة حكومية في
البلاد بنسبة خمسة واربعين
ورئيس حزب تحريك انصاف المعارض
عمران خان وقوات الامن تشتبك مع
المحتجين. موسكو تحتفل بعيد
النصر على النازية في موسكو
بسبب المعارك وبرغم سريان هدنة
بعد اخرى بين المتحاربين. ليتدخل
في رد مماثل على قرار الحكومة
الكندية بحق مسؤول بقنصلية الصين
الاحتلال. ليعلن بعدها وزير دفاع
الكيان ان حركة الجهاد اطلقت
والتطورات. على صعيد الرد بالمثل
اعلنت بكين طرد دبلوماسية كندية
ازالة الدولار من التعاملات
المالية والعمل على اتفاقية
والجوع ينخر الجسد السوداني. ولا
اعلنت منظمة اممية ارتفاع عدد
يعاني الامرين. في السودان الحال
يرثى له يا سادة. فلا ماء ولا
غبار هدوئها في الضفة الغربية
وردت في كمين محكم بتفجير عبوة
وبعد ان شنت قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي هجمات هي الاقوى منذ
القتلى المدنيين في الاشتباكات
بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في
مدة طويلة على غزة ونابلس لتعلن
بعدها وزارة الصحة الفلسطينية
بالمائة اعتبارا من يوليو
المقبل. مظاهرات حاشدة واحتجاجات
جماهيرية واسعة في باكستان بعد
اعتقال رئيس الوزراء السابق
اليات عسكرية اثناء الاقتحام مع
اصابات بالغة في صفوف قوات
التي لا تكاد تهدأ قليلا حتى يتم
نفض رمادها ليعود لهيبها هنا
عشرات الصواريخ على جنوبي وهذا
تحد لدولتنا بحسب قوله. لكن هنا
اعطى التعليمات لوزير الدفاع
والجيش للاستعداد لكل سيناريوهات
واحدة بواحدة فلتحاول مرة اخرى
اعلن حاكم مصرف ايران المركزي
واختناق سبعين شخصا مع اغتيال
ثلاثة من القادة العسكريين لحركة
محمد رضا فرزين ان بلاده ستستضيف
مؤتمرا الشهر المقبل للبحث في
اوتاوا بايداع التدخل في شئون
البلاد وكان الصين تقول لكندا
سودانية اذا رغبت الاطراف بذلك
فهل يفعلها هذا العثماني الاحداث
قال بان تركيا على استعداد
لاستضافة مفاوضات شاملة سودانية
السوداني عبدالفتاح البرهان في
بحث التطورات في السودان. هناك
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
شخصيا. ويتصل هاتفيا بقائد الجيش
السودان الى ستمائة واربعة اشخاص
وفرار اكثر من سبعمائة الف شخص
الجهاد الاسلامي في غزة ونابلس
جراء الغارات الاسرائيلية على
تل ابيب لا زالت في تخوف من الرد
الفلسطيني. نتنياهو يقول انه
القطاع. بين كانت مجموعة عرين
الاسود ونقصد المقاومة قد نفضت
تشتعل. هي حرب الماضي والحاضر هي
قضية العرب الدائمة. هي الحرب
والمحللون العسكريون انها كانت
خدعة ماكرة عن بدء تلقي قواته
ناسفة في قوة من الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ليتم اعطاب ثلاث
مهديا هذا النصر لفوتن وذلك
احتفالا بعيد النصر. جبهة فلسطين
الدخيرة من روسيا واضاف ان قواته
تقدمت لمسافة كبيرة في باخموت
وصفته بانتقاد قيادة جيش بلاده
والتي لم يستبعد السياسيون
الروسية على كييف في ثاني هجوم
من نوعه خلال يومين. ليعلن عمدة
تواصل كييف الحرب لكنها هذه
المرة كلامية. فبعد ان وصفت
في موسكو في احتفال يوم النصر
بانه خطوة غير اخلاقية وغير ودية
التصعيد. فما الذي تعد له
المقاومة الفلسطينية? السودان
استشهاد ثلاثة عشر مواطنا واصابة
عشرين اخرين بينهم نساء واطفال
تهديدات الالمان نفعا? بينما لم
تنفع الاسلحة يا حفيد هتلر. هنا
الاوكرانية. حيث وجدت قوات بوتين
الحل الذي سيعيق هجوم كييف
بوتين صواريخه ودباباته وجنوده.
انه لا يخيفنا. ونحن سنبقى
مهلا. نحن هنا نسمع صافرة انذار.
نعم. انها صافرات انذار كييف
النزاع. ومن هجمات موسكو العنيفة
الى طباخ بوتين وبعد ان نجحت
كييف ان العاصمة تعرضت لاكبر
هجوم بطائرات مسيرة منذ اندلاع
بجانب عدة مدن اوكراني تحذيرا من
هجمات روسية اطلقتها القوات
ذخيرتها الباهظة بحسب صحيفة
تلغراف البريطانية. مهلا مهلا
موسكو على تجنب العقوبات فهل
تلمح للصين يا ترى? ومن حروب
وبالفعل نسينا ان ناخذ رأي
النازيين بشأن ذلك. لينتقل
المضاد الذي يجري له منذ اشهر
ليظهر الروس ما يجعله بلا جدوى.
مواجهة التحايل على القيود
الحالية. اي انها لمن يساعد
الروسية وان يظل موحدا لدعم
اوكرانيا. مضيفا اليوم يستعرض
الالماني والذي قال ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي يجب الا يخاف من
تستخدمه روسيا بشكل فعال لدعم
القوة الجوية دون ان تستخدم
عشر الجديدة من عقوبات الاتحاد
الاوروبي ضد روسيا ستركز على
الاوروبيون الى حرب العقوبات.
حيث عادت تقول ان الحزمة الحادية
تجاه كييف ردت صاحبة الردود
اللازعة مرية زاخاروفا قائلة
مهيب. بوتين يأخذ استراحة محارب
ليظهر بعضا من قوة بلاده
موجعة. وتحت كل تلك الضربات
الكثيفة استقبل رئيس اوكرانيا
الزيارة في طياتها. هنا يظهر احد
قادة اوروبا ليجيب. انه المستشار
الخارجية الاوكرانية وجود قادة
بلدان من رابطة الدول المستقلة
الاستعراض ايها الدب الروسي.
هناك ايضا جدد بوتين اتهاماته
رئيسة المفوضية الاوروبية في
كييف. فما الذي تحمله هذه
نعم. انها القنابل المجنحة صغيرة
الحجم رخيصة الثمن. هي سلاح قديم
السياسة والاقتصاد نعود الى
الحرب الضارية على الارض
ثابتين في دعمنا لاوكرانيا بقدر
ما يتطلب الامر. لكن هل تجدي
المرعبة. والهدف ايصال رسالة
مشفرة. ومن الساحة الحمراء وفي
يحتفل بالنصر. ومع قرع طبول
الحرب. لا مانع في الطرف الاخر
البشرى للشعب التركي وباكستان
تدخل دوامة الحرب الاهلية. بوتين
ان تقرع طبول الاحتفال نعم نكسر
قانون الطوارئ وباستعراض عسكري
يعلن عن هجوم تاريخي مرتقب ضد
فلسطين. وعرين الاسود عن سواعدهم
تتحدث واي سلام يا هذا بينما
تشكو اوكرانيا من ضربة روسية
للدفاع الجوي وناقلة جنود مدرعات
وما خفي كان اعظم. فما كل هذا
وموسكو تريد ان ترى مستقبلا
يسوده السلام. فعن اي مستقبل
للغرب بانهم يريدون تدمير روسيا
قائلا العالم يشهد نقطة تحول
مدرعات من طراز تاجر وتايفون اوه
منظومات صواريخ اس اربعمائة
قلب العاصمة موسكو. ها هو يحتفل
بعيد النصر بمشاركة اكثر من عشرة
الاف فرد ومائة وخمس وعشرين قطعة
من المعدات العسكرية. فهنا
للغرب. ومجموعة فاجنر ترسل بهدية
للكرملين. الكيان الاسرائيلي
هو? بوتين يستعرض عضلاته الحربية
في يوم النصر ويبعث برسالة
وترسل باشارة لاوكرانيا فهل
اقتربت
والصين لكندا هذه بتلك والبادئ
اظلم. الرئاسة التركية تحمل
بانتظار ساعة الصفر. اردوغان
يدخل خط الوساطة في حرب السودان
المستشار الالماني بوتين لن
يخيفنا وسندعم اوكرانيا بكل ما
اوتينا من قوة. وسلاح روسي خطير
يوقف هجوم اوكرانيا المضاد. فما